it is December 1st 2022 the last month
of the year and so it's time for another
monthly update video I'll tell you what
we've got coming up in December and what
you might have missed in November but we
always begin with three big things so
big thing number one stoicism today uh
selected essays volume 4 is now
available not just in paperback but in
Kindle I'm really happy to have that out
and available for everybody especially
if you want to buy a gift for somebody
for the holidays
um big thing number two as usual we're
going to be having a solicitation of
suggestions and then a vote for the
worlds of speculative fiction series
I'll be putting out a video talking
about the people that we're doing for
2023 and looking for viewer suggestions
about people we haven't already done so
that'll be some great participatory
stuff and then big thing number three
look out for classes that are going to
start rolling out in December but also
even more so in 2023 as I scale back on
some activities I'm going to be putting
a lot more time into developing online
classes for lifelong Learners and
anybody else who wants to study
philosophy and other topics so those are
the three big things to keep an eye out
for let's talk now about November I
thought that the month of November was
going to be a time for me to get an
awful lot done it didn't quite pan out
that way in part because you know once I
finished with uh stoicon there were
still several more talks to give and you
know the semester is is proceeding we're
getting to the very end of classes and
so there's been a lot of focusing on
other things that I you know kept me
from getting some of the projects done
that I wanted to do I did have two talks
that I gave on one day somehow things
lined up that way one was philosophers
in the midst of History a local talk
here with a video of which is available
below focusing on Maurice Blondell the
great French Catholic philosopher who's
sometimes called the French or Catholic
Hegel the person I wrote my dissertation
on that day I also gave a talk virtually
at the University of würzburg
specifically on Epictetus and reasons
and and character and the probably
racist or the faculty of of will for
worlds of speculative fiction this month
I focused on Philip K dick and a number
of his stories that have to do with
Androids and humans so obviously to
Android's Dream of Electric Sheep but
also the simulacra we can build you we
looked at some of his essays and even
part of the exegesis I was invited as a
speaker to stoicon X Midwest I was
actually the only midwesterner
presenting there
and talked about stoicism and religion
and there were various other events you
know I did my usual Hegel get-togethers
philosophy chat
um you know we had a wisdom for Life
show as well and I started teaching my
light Hall class which is still ongoing
about platonic dialogues which I'll
probably reprise again in 2023 for
people who are interested in that but
not on light Hall rather in the study
with Sadler Academy it was a you know
busy month
um
I got back to the gym which is very good
and I've been taking in a pretty regular
walks
um you know some other things going on
obviously Thanksgiving holiday we had a
pretty low-key Thanksgiving here which
is exactly what I needed and you know
got some writing done not as much as I
would have liked necessarily but that's
something that we're going to try to do
more of in December and in 2023 and you
know I'm teaching my academic classes uh
one at Milwaukee Institute of Art and
Design three at Marquette University
that's been taking a lot of time as well
um videos I did get one half hour Hegel
video done and so we've got a little bit
of forward momentum going on with that
I'm hoping to finish the series in 2023.
um there's also a wisdom for Life show
video from uh episode uh 60. it was kind
of cool that we got that far I did a
saddlers asides and digressions video
Sadler stories video
um and then there were videos from the
different events the stoicon X the
presentation at University at würzburg
the philosophers in the midst of history
of course the Philip K dick so you can
see links to all of those below and I
did a quick take video that actually uh
got a lot of traction people seem to
have liked it quite a bit responding to
a comment that somebody had sent me
um about prioritizing and whether you
can actually do it all or not the answer
is of course you cannot do it all and
then I also did quite a few core concept
videos
um much of which are for my class on
anger that I'm teaching this semester at
Marquette so some of them on John
chrysostom's sermons uh some on
plutarch's work on anger and then I took
some of the business ethics videos that
I'd done years ago for my online
business ethics class
specifically silke Mack hold and her
fellow authors talking about the ethics
of care in corporations and governance
so you know a lot of work on videos I
also did quite a bit of podcast editing
we finished up the sequence on Arthur
schopenhauer is on the basis of morality
a very short sequence following that on
Audrey Lords the uses of anger and then
uh eight episode series on Joseph
Butler's
work on uh or his his sermons uh
specifically about anger as homilies and
then Aristotle book 10 I uh did a I
think a seven uh set series on that and
we just started doing Cicero's on duties
as well
so that was uh November kind of a packed
month uh let's talk now about the month
ahead
so quite a few things coming up in the
month of December on the third uh the
first Saturday of the month I'll have my
usual ask me anything AMA session
followed at two o'clock with a patreon
exclusive philosophy chat it's one of
the perks that my patreon supporters get
to participate in then skipping ahead to
the 14th which is a Wednesday at 5 p.m
we'll have our usual Hegel q a and
discussion session that's a video
conferencing session that anybody can
join in on if they want to it's
underwritten by the half hour Hegel
project on the 17th at noon we will be
having the next worlds of speculative
fiction series it's going to be focused
on the Hyperion cantos of Dan Simmons
we're only going to be reading the first
two books because each of them is super
long and so we're going to be reading
Hyperion and fall of Hyperion and we're
going to be pushing off the rest of the
cantos to next year so that'll be a
video premiere release that we'll have
live chat on followed by a video
conferencing session
on the 24th I'm going to do a video
premiere of a self-directed study video
I haven't decided yet which thinker I'm
going to focus on but something starting
that series back up it's been very
helpful for people and then finally on
the 29th we'll have our Milwaukee stoic
Fellowship online meeting and talk about
what we're going to do for the year to
come I might actually slip a few other
events in there depending on my energy
level and what I'm inclined to do but
we'll we'll see and there'll be
announcements in social media about this
obviously you can also listen to the
wisdom for Life show every Saturday at 5
PM Central Time by the way all the times
that I've given here are central time so
if you are going to participate in them
make sure you that you know what time
zone you're in
classes are going to be coming to a
close
and uh you know so I've got a lot of
grading I'll be doing about the midpoint
of the month Marquette finishes a week
later than Milwaukee Institute of Art
and Design does so I've you know I've
got a lot of uh you know sort of
administrative things to do and Grading
and then the semester is over and I
begin planning for my new classes in the
spring I've got two lined up at
Milwaukee Institute of Art and Design
both of which I've taught in the past
but they always get retweaked and new
stuff so I'm going to be teaching
um what's called intro to Humanities
next semester and I'll be shooting some
new videos for that and I'm teaching a
philosophy as a way of life class as
well so you know we'll be focusing on
the epicureans and the cynics and the
stoics and we'll see who else I want to
mix into that one
I'll also be bringing out some as I
mentioned in the three big things some
classes for a general audience that
anybody who wants to can sign up for and
participate in
um that those will all be in the study
with Sadler Academy
rather than academic classes these are
not for credit these are for personal
enrichment and I'll be teaching quite a
few and developing quite a few of those
some of which will be rolling out in
later in December
um so a lot of that going on I'm going
to try to get more writing done in
medium I'm also uh going to be starting
back up the newsletter that I had years
ago it's about time that I start uh
making that work again so if you're in
the newsletter list you'll see it coming
out if not there's opportunities to sign
up for it that I will you'll see in
social media and things like that
um what else is going on
um well I'll be doing a lot of video
work this month uh core concept videos
I've got a number on David hume's
inquiry concerning human understanding
ready to start shooting on pretty soon
I've also got some stuff that I meant to
get to on Blaze pascals passes that I'll
be shooting some videos about Thomas
Aquinas I've got some stuff that I need
to produce as well
if I get around to it I might shoot some
more stuff on seneca's work on anger
um and there'll be um you know quite a
few other things as well
um I'm gonna do some book reviews that
I've been wanting to get to for quite a
while might shoot some more Sadler
stories videos
um I've got some speculative fiction
studies things that I need to finish up
that I never got to in the past for
example on Ursula Kayla Queens Earthsea
stuff and I've got a few other things I
want to do on speculative fiction and
then of course half hour Hegel I'm going
to try to get at least four videos done
which will take us out of the religion
section and into the absolute knowing uh
section if I'm not mistaken
we might actually it might take four to
get us out of the religion section and
then I'm gonna do a video on something
that I've been thinking about for a
while there's a lot of Greg and Gregory
sadlers out there and I've been kind of
curious well what do these people do
what's their shtick you know one of them
is a political candidate
um others are musicians there's all
sorts of other interesting professions
that these different saddlers have so
I'm going to do a video about that and
we'll we'll see what I turn up in my
research
podcast work I am in the middle of
Cicero's on duties that will probably
take me through a good portion of the
month because I you know what I do with
the core concept videos is convert them
to Sadler's lectures podcast episodes
and it turned out there were 22 of them
on on duties book one so that'll last
quite a while and then what I might do
is
I'll maybe run another poll about who
should come after that I've got a number
of different ways I could go with
additional
um
uh podcast episodes you know so we'll
we'll leave it up to the viewers to
decide so again you'll see that coming
out in my social media as well
and I'll put a poll in in YouTube as
well so that's a lot already going on
and that takes us to the end of the year
I'll probably do like a video about end
of the year wrap up what went well what
didn't go well we'll see how much
ambition I have by the time we get to
the end of the month and we're
approaching the new year so I hope that
uh December uh closes out the year well
for all of you and maybe I'll see you in
some of these online events and uh
otherwise have a great holiday season
and I'll see you uh Somewhere In The
Ether